this video is brought to you by Ray Khan
hey wisecrack michael here let me ask
you something how is it that YouTube
correctly guesses time and time again
that I need more dr. Gregory Johnson in
my life make sure you keep your clothes
in other words how and why does YouTube
use information gathered from search
history say a one time query for epic
back cracking to send us down rabbit
holes filled with highly specific
content whether that be chiropractic
adjustments zit popping or ASMR for that
matter how do social media sites take
into account my friend groups stated
political and entertainment preferences
and browsing habits to serve up ads that
are annoying but often chillingly
relevant the above are well-known
examples of big data in action but it's
not all ring dingers and soap cutting
while big data hasn't doubtedly provided
us with some cool and useful things like
predicting disease outbreaks or
cataloging the Milky Way it's also
influencing your life and far more
subtle and often spooky ways big data
can and has been used to predict who
will become pregnant in order to more
effectively target ads diagnose
depression remotely again for the
express purpose of marketing goods and
services determine political leanings
evaluate teachers and make predictions
about when employees might quit these
and other big data uses are squirrely
enough on their own while most people
are just creeped out by the general
concept of some modern-day Big Brother
creeping on their porn browsing habits
we often overlook one of the most
important parts of big data its
organization we made balk at how it's
gathered sure but what happens after
that how do you take a sea of data and
turn it into an efficient ring dinger
delivering machine and how does the
answer to that question pose one of the
biggest problems for society in the 21st
century welcome to this wisecrack
edition on big data but before we get
into it I want to give a shout out to
Ray Khan if you've been on the fence
about getting a pair of wireless earbuds
I'm here to tell you that ray con
earbuds are a game changer we're all
really busy people and sometimes you
just need to be free of those pesky
wired headphones whether it's working
out at the gym washing your dishes or
simply laying in bed after a long day
you deserve to listen to your favorite
songs or podcasts
with a full range of motion they fit
discreetly in your ears and are
comfortable to wear for long periods of
time perfect for long runs drives are
just walking around being alive don't
believe me each pair comes with
different ear tips sizes so you can get
the most comfortable fit their latest
model that a 25 is the best yet with six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and a compact design
that gives you a nice noise isolating
fit rekha-ii earbuds are half the price
of other premium wireless brands so
there's no reason not to grab a pair
today click the link in the description
or go to buy rake on Comm slash
wisecrack and you can get 15% off your
order that's by rake on.com slash
wisecrack now back to the show
in 2020 it's fairly common knowledge
that internet giants like Google Bing
Yahoo and Facebook gather user data
through search engines user profiles and
other touch points but there are many
other data collection hotspots available
the companies looking to rake in that
sweet sweet marketing insight though
many of the largest internet companies
also gather data through subsidiary
services that the average user might
consider a bit more private think for
instance of your email inbox your
phone's location data or the
high-concept mortal engine that you have
saved on Google Drive like one traction
city eating a smaller traction City tech
giant's gobble up user data at every
possible opportunity and the practice
doesn't stop with just Google or
Facebook data brokers such as axiom
Equifax KBM and credit card companies by
consumer data from smaller companies in
order to repackage and sell it to larger
companies certain health information
collected by insurance companies is also
bought and sold as our data points
gathered from quantified self gadgets
such as Garmin retail loyalty programs
satellite imagery employer databases
bank records and records of online
gaming behavior to oversimplify a bid
companies collect this data not to
improve consumer experience as they
often claim but to provide more and
better direct marketing opportunities to
advertisers the end goal in other words
is profit which only happens to coincide
with a more streamlined consumer
experience for instance big data isn't
used to create games which have more
entertainment value it's used to create
games which keep people playing and pain
through both subscription fees and
microtransactions
in a more grisly example when data
analyst Alex Pentland managed to obtain
anonymous location data on credit-card
usage he and his team were able to use
it to predict with a high degree of
accuracy which card users were
experiencing depression they found that
depressed folks tend to travel shorter
distances when making purchases than
those without depression so the tighter
the circle of card usage the higher the
probability the card user was suffering
from mental illness pharmaceutical
companies were able to use this
information to start marketing directly
to specific individuals now people have
long had their qualms about whether this
sort of data should even be gathered in
the first place
you took my sonar concept and applied it
to every phone in the city but half the
city feeling you saw not you can image
all of the other this is wrong rather
than dwell on whether or not it's okay
for someone to watch us poop through our
smartphone cameras we're going to focus
on what people are doing with that data
instead the basic problem is that people
are organizing data in a way that's
entirely opaque to the outside world and
deploying it in a way that could
profoundly alter your life all this has
sold us on the basic assumption that
something an algorithm tells us is
objective and true that decisions made
by them are proper and natural after all
who can argue with basic math spoiler
alert this guy but hold on isn't data
objective you'd certainly think so after
all raw data is just that objective
facts facts like how many Americans own
dogs or how many times it snowed this
year but as you might have guessed
knowing exactly how many bowel movements
occurred in America in 1987 does not a
data scientist to make to perform its
function as a tool for framing the
president in predicting the future data
must be organized to tell a particular
story we need to connect the dots this
is a necessary part of interpretation
isolated facts have to be turned into
narrative and that involves picking and
choosing what data matters to the story
and excluding data that doesn't it also
involves interpreting how those
different pieces of data connect for
example the number of new Nicolas Cage
films correlates to more people falling
and drowned
to death and swimming pools that year is
something I should consider for my next
pool party whenever an act of
interpretation happens it becomes one
person's interpretation versus another
person's interpretation for instance
where one lawyer sees standard business
activity another sees light one
interpretation can benefit one person
and screw another so in the world of
data who is benefiting and who is
getting boned
you'd think opportunity for said boning
would be minimal after all this is data
we're talking about right
how can objective facts be unfair or
biased data scientists can't make one in
one equal three the problem however is
that big data stops being purely
objective once humans get involved which
is to say a hundred percent of the time
that's because those humans have to
interpret and organize data or program a
computer to interpret it how they see
fit data is organized by algorithms and
models when these models are constructed
well they arrange data in ways that
provide incredibly valuable information
when they are made poorly they can be
misused to prop up self-fulfilling
prophecies that screw over a ton of
people while enriching their creators
let's have a look at the difference
through the lens of what some people
might say is the world's most boring
sport baseball have you've ever read
Moneyball or seen the Jonah Hill movie
or are just a sports fan you may be
aware that baseball uses a ton of data
many of us are vaguely familiar with
RBIs and batting averages but there are
plenty of other data points to collect
over the course of a game enough even to
predict who is more likely to win or
lose in other words it's possible to use
data to model a player's performance and
oftentimes these models determine who
gets hired or fired in baseball seems
cold well it's actually not that bad
that's because these models are
transparent players are fully aware of
them they know for instance that their
on-base percentage is low that their
managers are considering trading them as
a results and that they need to bring it
up if they want to keep their jobs it
was a lot more
good question yes compare this to say
the YouTube algorithm which promotes and
D monetizes content and a proprietary
manner that is completely inaccessible
to the creator's being judged by it or
teachers who in some cases have been
fired as a result of value-added
modelling without even understanding how
that modelling works algorithms and
models are also being used to give out
loans and credit cards or to deny or
approve parole for prisoners as
mathematician Cathy O'Neil notes in her
book weapons of mass destruction the
proprietary nature of these models means
that unlike statistics in baseball they
are not open to scrutiny so if I make
claims about what kind of players with
what kind of data will score homeruns
and win games people can laugh me out of
town when those players fail
spectacularly people make predictions
and then are held accountable if those
predictions don't play out models are
tweaked people are fired and so on but
if a mysterious model says that these
teachers will make your kids dumber and
these teachers will make your kids
smarter no such scrutiny generally
exists as O'Neil points out companies go
out of their way to hide the results of
their models or even their existence
such well-defended company algorithms
form a massive ever-present black box in
our day-to-day lives we know what goes
in our data and what comes out
organizational decisions whether they be
marketing strategies or police patrol
patterns but the average person has no
idea what goes on in the middle
what's important is deciding which
factors go into making the model which
by necessity is always a simplification
not a perfect representation of the real
world process we want to analyze or
predict done right modeling cuts out a
great deal of noise while offering
useful predictions for instance avionics
software is useful to pilots and air
traffic controllers bukka's attracts air
speed wind direction in the locations of
landing strips while excluding other
potential data points like building
locations street games and restaurant
reviews Google Maps does track those
things and not others making it a useful
tool for someone trying to make their
way to Taco Bell models are created by
people trying to achieve a particular
goal like winning baseball games but
people are inevitably influenced by
their own ideologies and the way they go
about collecting data and in the stories
they choose to tell about
that data as O'Neill puts it models are
opinions embedded in that matters again
and isn't numbers or data points
themselves that can reflect by us but
the ways in which we interpret large
numbers of data points this can be
further aggravated when we use those
interpretations to inform what data will
gather in the future if we're not
careful we can wind up creating
algorithms and models that are designed
consciously or unconsciously
to reinforce our existing world view
this is particularly important to keep
in mind today when as O'Neill explains
poorly made or deliberately misleading
models can encode human prejudices
misunderstandings or biases into the
software systems that increasingly
manage our lives this bias already has a
significant impact on jurisdictions
around the country that use pred for a
predictive policing service in theory
pred poll uses raw data on crimes
committed in a given area to predict
when and where crime is likely to occur
again think Minority Report but with
less hand-waving and more math in
practice pred Ball has been shown to set
up an unfortunate feedback loop in
response to a crime it sends more
officers to a given neighborhood
increasing the likelihood that those
officers will find and report someone
committing a crime there which will in
turn result in more patrols this in turn
raises the neighborhoods profile as a
hotbed of criminal activity in the eyes
of the algorithm and therefore the
police department even though the actual
crime rate has remained constant so if
you're the type to enjoy a leisurely
stroll while puffing on a jazz cigarette
you'll probably be fine assuming you
live in a neighborhood that is wealthy
and white but if you live in an area
where pred bull has sent increased
patrols because of an abundance of
pickle ric graffiti you might just get
arrested then consider that some
research suggests sending people to
prison makes them more likely to commit
other crimes and the feedback loop gets
worse the issues with modeling are
compounded even further by the fact that
most of us have no idea what the hell is
going on during the design process big
data models use data to create very
specific stories about people in groups
but those algorithms are not created by
or understood by the people they're
telling stories about this is not an
accident unlike baseball players who can
use their publicly reported stats to
focus their training efforts and improve
their performance
we can't readily access
but he held data that might help us
improve our own lives for instance what
if we knew the factors that
statistically might sabotage our diet
plans like a bad day at work or walking
past a delicious pie shop on our way
home that knowledge can empower us to
make different choices or change our
habits but that would also result in us
buying fewer pies which would in turn be
very bad for big pie in other words far
better to keep companies profitable
while we are ignorant Lee belching a
boysenberry consumer algorithms and
models are valuable to companies
precisely because they are hard for the
average consumer to access and interpret
but it gets even worse because the
little that we do know about Big Data
namely that we are being constantly
tracked still can have a tangible impact
on our behavior the reason has to do
with privacy which law professor Julie
Cohen defines as shorthand for breathing
room to engage in the process of
self-development big data takes a giant
meat cleaver to that breathing room
which Cowan argues means that we lose
the ability to choose which parts of our
life we share with others so maybe
you're not quite ready to publicly try
and fail at writing your first murder
mystery but would love to do so
privately but in the age of the internet
you can't watch a video on arsenic
poisoning without YouTube making
judgments about who you are as a person
and with the power of recommended videos
it will likely serve you content that
will slowly turn you into that person
you watch one video of feet and forever
the algorithm thinks you're a weird feet
guy when our every embarrassing selfie
search query and online purchase is
logged on a server somewhere out in
Silicon Valley we are reduced to our
foibles and shortcomings little box will
be on countless TVs around the world
feeding me credit-card numbers bank wise
this all seems complicated enough but
trust me the situation gets even weirder
because an algorithm that can be
genuinely useful in one context can
cause lasting harm in another so what
happens when a highly specific algorithm
goes mad with power
you get the credit score system it was
originally meant to determine whether or
not the bank should lend you money to
start a fondue chain or something today
credit scores are used to make decisions
about housing applications and even
employment so if you missed a credit
card payment because you lost your job
good luck finding a new one the
gathering organization and
implementation of Big Data raise some
thorny questions around the issue of
free will which both Aristotle and
Thomas Aquinas believe is one of the
core traits that distinguishes the human
from the animal or the Machine knowing
what we do know about the role Big Data
plays in our lives how do we reconcile
the fact that so many of our decisions
seem to be beyond their reach of our
conscious Minds to put it bluntly how do
we make free choices about where and how
we work if theoretically banking models
browsing history and likelihood of
pregnancy or depression can keep
otherwise qualified candidates out of
job pools how do we exercise our free
will in our social lives when Facebook
and other social media companies control
what we see in our feeds and who we are
most likely to interact with under the
circumstances how do we stay human
philosophy professor Collin Koopman
believes that we may require whole new
fields of study to find the answers to
these and other questions surrounding
Big Data Koopman points out that to date
our society has always played catch-up
with big data new database technologies
are allowed to emerge pretty much
without restraint and only after the
fact and rarely do we put regulations in
place to control them to put it another
way we've taken a developed first ask
questions later approach to data science
to form an idea about how we might move
forward Koopman looks to medicine law
and other complex fields with entrenched
ethical codes these codes help consumers
because if say your lawyer snitches on
you they can be disbarred in a similar
way data science and the millions of us
affected by it every day may benefit
from commonly held enforceable standards
or at the very least it might encourage
brands to stop hovering over our
shoulders like a bunch of creepy street
hawkers wanna buy
sundial so what do you think wisecrack
will we be able to turn big data into a
transparent tool used for the benefit of
all or will biased algorithms continue
to enable unfair treatment under the
guise of math and science is there
another way forward that we haven't
considered let us know your thoughts in
the comments below and as always thanks
for watching later
[Music]